alright boys we handed a little king of
the sting it god damn you know that
videos [ __ ] class first we got our
boy a little bone Jones everybody
oh well BJ with bone Jones hey Theo hey
Brandon the Sebastian on a Garland Texas
and I got a king at her sting okay
brother guys with nipple piercings gang
gang buzz buzz well look here's you
gotta get him treated though don't get
the untreated ones cuz they rust and
that's what I've seen yeah you don't go
cheap with the nipple piercings but also
don't do them you don't do MTV Spring
Break 1997 we can't do that dude you
can't get [ __ ] tattoos and you can't
get nipple piercings you also really
can't have a long hair like that anymore
you know and why is it so wet this is
here so wet
dude he probably just got baptized or
something this guy looks like a quality
young fellow it's like a patriot though
I'll give them that
Oh aim small miss small man this dude
would get it done against the Brits okay
I'll tell you that in the heart yeah if
there's a problem you ain't lying bro
I'll he'll put though he'll put the
Queen and a casket if he had to you know
what I'm saying this guy could get it
done bra it Winston Churchill got
nothing on this little badge the only
time I like piercings is if I'm at a
strip club some girl some big old Tenace
and once pierced interesting cuz you
look like the kind of guy that would
have your nipples pierced
really I feel like you would know after
that rap video I like you and your bro
get your nipples pierced and spent all
your money on [ __ ] chicken wings at
yeah but I'll say this get the pre
treated ones if you do get that pre
treated you know you don't want the ones
that have that will rust man huh I'm
arose out of Lake not too long ago in
Oklahoma and they had a guy out there
and he had one of his nipple rings was
rusted I was like man s it could be
vintage you got to get the treatment on
it on that steel dude I just I don't see
the benefits to a do unless you're the
Sun hits it when you got your chest out
in the Sun that could be cool like a
wolf look from far away what was
oh uh I gotta just I don't see the
benefits man yeah yeah I feel like you'd
hurt like a [ __ ]
you've dead sis have you had your nipple
pierced no never never
what if you had that nose pierced my
ears a couple times no mock piercing my
nose dude cuz other Bulls will come from
so what I pierced my ears probably five
or six times and I was a child you know
i mighta pierced I'll pierce something I
had like a growth on my hip I think we
pierced it one night pierced I'm all cat
you just your ears are pierced have you
had anything else nope I am not fond of
piercings I like tattoos those are the
only type of needles I can do Jim Lee
tattoos yeah you do yeah okay we went
over this I got one on my side and then
I'm getting another one in November what
are you getting November on my arm yeah
you didn't sleep DUP just my forearm I
feel like you look sexy a little nose
piercing just a little ring I thought
about it I'm I bet you look cool does
your sister have one no Hillary up just
tattoos that surprises me that's
surprising yeah well uh I'm against
nipple piercing were you on nipple
piercing I'm out it seems like a hassle
boat like TSA security you have to take
out your [ __ ] nipples with your shoes
yeah somebody will steal them to it
security they steal [ __ ]
plus your girl dimension girls are slick
in your nipple it's Paris my sexy dude I
think it's brave though I think the dude
look man this guy obviously likes to
[ __ ] I think that this guy [ __ ] outdoors
and I respect that
go put on some [ __ ] he looks like you
put on some Bruce Springsteen and [ __ ]
your brains out King
[Music]
the king nothing
[Music]